[Music]
you know Damien my partners don't tend
to last too long play it fast and loose
he's got a problems load doesn't he go
check it out yeah
[Music]
we're gonna write these guys up you
gonna let him go I'm gonna help them
with the furniture so you don't think we
need to shoot anybody
sir if these mattress tags appear to be
in order
none appear to have been removed
[Music]
hello ma'am
good to see everything okay here anybody
around here give me any trouble
nope you haven't seen anything gone
missing lately actually they did take
some blades from me their little box
cutters this is important
did you file a report negative and we
thought it wasn't worth it when small
blades go missing it usually means
something's up in this town I'm telling
you something's happening in Alvarado I
just smell trouble
maybe I ought to go check and uh I don't
know David's okay they have some I saw
some old product in there before like
the old candy bar so be careful you
think you're selling old candy bars yeah
I think so any bars past expiration
point but this was a couple months ago
so the trails gonna colder couple of
months ago why didn't you report this
what is your name Sam okay sandy all
right I like you sandy okay I like you
too you what's your name my name is
Conan Conan I state your name I want you
to thank you certainly well thank you so
much barrier you know I never heard that
movie like a big guy buff guy you know
I'll be back
no never know what someone want to eat
you better go home watching TV I hate TV
we hate the people on it I better go
there you go god bless have a good one
you too
excuse me ma'am mass be cheap for just a
second you find a chocolate in there any
chocolate bars
oh yeah they're open you can come on in
this is why have people just leaving
when they see me they see us and they
leave what does that tell you
guilty building something is this your
store here it is this is your
consignment shop it is can I ask you if
you've seen any suspicious activity in
the area other than you guys seeming to
run everybody out of day but snow here
there's many candy bars over at David's
and expired and box cutter blades are
missing over the general store I think
they're linked I'm telling you Damien
there is something going on here I've
been a lawman for over 48 minutes
something's not right
mister God next door his name is Sam you
know as Sam and using some new box
cutter blades recently eating any
expired candy not that this thing's
starting to come together
My partner and I took a trip to Alvarado
today and there's a lot there that
doesn't add up
first of all we went to the Alvarado
County store we talked to a woman there
a very suspicious woman with the
Superman tattoo on her hand and Batman
tattooed she said that box cutter blades
had gone missing is that correct yes
box cutter blades we then proceeded on
her information over to David's market
where we found out that there was
expired chocolate that led us across the
street to a consignment shop led by a
guy with a beer Brian Brian the bee
means beard who's this Brian guy why
don't we have any Intel on what about
Sam what about Sam I see a triangle it's
what I see and what's at the center of
that triangle in that town square a
gazebo there's a gazebo at the center of
that town square I think if you dig up
that gazebo you'll find $600,000 of
cocaine
you don't think so I don't
Sam and Brian are in on it together if I
were you I'd arrest Sam and I would
shoot Brian preferably in the back I'm
leaving you guys this and you're welcome
it's pretty much ready to crack I'm
gonna fly to LA get a spa treatment that
will include a facial I'm going to drive
to the airport and fire my gun randomly
out the window
good idea
[Applause]